hillsdale k-12 education what the
hillsdale 1776 curriculum is how it came
about and its underlying principles
dr o'toole
hey thanks jordan and thanks everyone
for joining
i'm just just scrolling through the list
of people who are here and i see some
familiar names so whether you're in the
process of starting a
hillsdale-affiliated school or a teacher
or a former teacher in those schools i
especially welcome you
i have a couple of jobs this morning as
jordan or this afternoon actually as
jordan said the first one is to tell you
about hillsdale college and our work in
k-12 education and then i'd like to give
you an introduction to the 1776
curriculum talk to you about what it is
where it came from
and then i'll send it back to jordan who
will take you through the curriculum and
give you a tour
we are very eager for your questions
part of the goal here is to help people
who are interested in using the
curriculum or curious about its purposes
understand it and so please do use that
q a or that chat and we'll allow plenty
of time for questions at the end
okay um i'm going to talk to you about
k-12 education at hillsdale college and
i'm going to do that with the help of a
very handy visual aid which is going to
pop up in just a second
hillsdale college as you
may know
is
is an old institution
and an unusual institution
jordan can you confirm that everyone can
see that okay
yeah that's right it's up
okay great
um so hillsdale college is a liberal
arts college in southern michigan we are
177 years old we're in our 177th year
our roots are in
free will baptists who started this
school
we are famous for sending nearly all of
our student body to fight in the in the
civil war
um so campus just completely emptied of
of young men during the uh during the
civil war
and that's partly because the roots of
the of the college are abolitionist
roots if you look at a picture of the
first graduating class of hillsdale
college there are women
in that class and there's an
african-american man in that class and
that was basically unheard of in
american colleges at the time
and that has to do with our idea going
back to the very beginning that the very
best education should be available to
everyone
today hillsdale college is remarkable
because of its refusal to accept federal
funds that allows us to or state funds
that
allows us to be truly independent
when we we have the freedom here to say
what we think and to do what we think is
right
and all of our work is made possible by
friends of the college who believe in
its mission
what that means is that hillsdale
college is involved in a lot more than
just the education of undergraduates
although and graduate students although
that is of course our primary purpose
and the the reason that we exist day in
and day out
we have 1500 students here at the
college and two graduate schools one
more graduate program on the way
and
in addition to that we host online
courses which are free
and enjoyed by
adults and children
across the country and we also have been
working in k-12 education for a long
time which is our subject today
hillsdale college
has been working in k-12 education for
30 years just over 30 years we have a
private
classical school here on campus called
hillsdale academy
and we have
for over 10 years now been working
through the barney charter school
initiative
to help local groups of citizens start
classical schools originally charter
schools but now charter and private
schools that bring the same education in
the liberal arts and sciences that our
undergraduate and graduate students
receive to k-12 students
my own my own
work with hillsdale college began when i
was the founding headmaster of one of
these classical schools and
today i lead these efforts
and help the college be as effective as
possible with our outreach to k through
12.
i'll leave it up to you to decide
whether it's going well we try hard
here at the college we believe that
every american student deserves the very
best education
that exists
we think that the very best curriculum
the very best works that have ever been
that have ever been written
the very best
methods that have ever been discovered
for teaching
and the very best teachers
should be in front of every american
student and so we work hard through the
through the barney charter school
initiative and our other work to make
this american classical education we
call it
available to
students of
students in every neighborhood students
of every background
we want the schools that we work with to
be excellent in their teaching of course
in what they teach and how they teach it
but also in their operations so we work
with groups to make sure that the
institutions that they they are starting
are sound institutions institutions that
will stand the test of time
and our goal is that
students receive this well-rounded
education in the liberal arts and the
sciences
not a career-focused education
or a specific type of training but
rather an education that will provide
them with knowledge of themselves
knowledge of the world around them so
that when they reach college and
adulthood and whatever comes after k-12
they have a solid foundation from which
to proceed
we also recognize that students don't
just learn
content or information while they're in
school if you visit a hillsdale school
you'll see that kids are learning real
science real history real literature
from the very earliest days of
kindergarten
but we don't think that our job is
merely to fill their minds full of
information
we also recognize that as you go through
your k-12 years
you as a student are turning into the
person that you are going to become
you're receiving a moral education an
idea about what is right and what is
wrong an idea about how you should live
your life and every student receives
this education from his or her school
and family whether or not the school
intends to give it by sending your child
to a school you're sending your child to
a
a group of adults and children who are
going to teach that child big things
about right and wrong
whether well or not well
so we think since they're going to learn
so much
about how to live and what is
choice-worthy in life and since their
characters are going to be transforming
so dramatically over the course of their
education we should pay attention to the
content of that education we should make
sure that we're teaching young men and
women to be people of character people
of virtue
people who don't just know things and
know how to think but people who are
solid and will make choices that are
good for themselves and good for those
who are around them
so that's a little bit about our mission
it's happening in schools across the
country and it's a very exciting thing
to see
on the topic of education
i wanted to point something out about
education
this is a quotation from a speech that
frederick douglass gave
if you know anything about the story of
frederick douglass you know that he was
he's a remarkable person and even more
remarkable when you consider his
beginnings
he visited hillsdale college in the
early days
and one of the most famous pictures of
him that's ever been taken was taken
here on campus and we have an original
of it in our archives which is
pretty amazing
we don't know where he gave this speech
exactly but it's possible that he gave
this speech at hillsdale college and we
hope that he did
because it's it's got some beautiful
lines in it
one of the things that he
he spoke about was the nature of
education and he said that education is
freedom education means emancipation
it means taking the soul of an
individual human being and raising that
person up into the light of truth it
means taking what we are naturally
and helping us become more than that by
exposing us to something that is greater
and better than ourselves
he went on to say that denying this
education preventing people from having
this opportunity is one of the greatest
crimes against human nature
we agree with douglas and we think that
if students are not educated properly
then
their possibilities in life are limited
in the most fundamental way and so for
us this mission is an urgent mission
it's a mission of the utmost importance
and
it's something that i think
i think that
we are we are seeing
among parents and among teachers in this
country kind of a renewed attention to
and we think that's a very good thing
let me tell you about hillsdale's work
with all of these classical schools we
work with
they are all over the country
and they're in every type of
neighborhood you can imagine and they're
very different from each other except
that they are all faithful to this
mission of bringing the liberal arts and
sciences bringing this curriculum and
this way of teaching classically to
to the students than the families that
they serve
today we're working with 49 schools
across the country
20 of these are what we call member
schools these are schools that we have
helped to found schools that we we
worked with from the very beginning to
establish
and
they've
you know there are various ages some of
them are very new some of them are more
established
and although we don't own or operate any
of these schools we work extremely
closely with their boards with their
teachers with their principals and we
feel a great deal of responsibility for
their success
we have a team of people here at the
college who's constantly on the road
visiting these schools they come here to
the college for conferences all the time
and we're in a giant discussion with
each other all the time
about how to educate young people using
the very best curriculum and the very
best teaching
we uh we learned
we've been going for 12 years in the
barney charter school initiative and one
of the things that we've learned is that
there are a lot of schools out there
both private schools and public schools
that want to be more classical they want
to do classical education and they've
been knocking on our door for a decade
now saying can you
you know can we come too
and it's a beautiful thing
and so eventually we figured out a way
to help schools that already exist
benefit from a lot of the resources that
we provide here at hillsdale including
among or above all the curriculum
and so we have 29 schools across the
country and more applying every month to
use this k-12 curriculum that we teach
in our schools
it's an excellent curriculum and it
provides both to use teacher-speak
vertical and horizontal alignment for
the school it's a way for a school to
make sure that what it's doing with its
youngest students is paving the way for
what happens with older students and
it's a way for the entire school to be
in a conversation with itself
about what is taught and how should that
be taught
sometimes these things are left up to
individual teachers or school becomes
very disjointed and segmented and our
curriculum in addition to being
excellent
is cohesive it allows the entity the
school to function as a cohesive whole
let me show you where our schools are
they're all over the country
you'll see here schools with flags those
are our member schools those are schools
we have help to found
and if they have a gray flag then we're
working now to help found them
we've got board members from many of
these schools on campus right now
uh doing uh doing one of our semi-annual
board development sessions
so we're actively working with the
people across the country who are
founding those schools with the gray
flags
if you see a blue dot that's a school
that pre-existed
before they started working with us but
that wants to become more classical in
some way
these schools
learn from this curriculum they use it
in whatever way is helpful to them
and if they want to
if they want to you know apply for
membership in our initiatives and begin
you know coming to our conferences and
receiving feedback and visits from
hillsdale's team
after using the curriculum for a couple
of years they can apply for that
and that's a way for us to
we hope
do do good things for k-12 education
across the country
before i move on let me just mention
that all of these schools are
independent we don't own or operate any
of them except for hillsdale academy
which is part of hillsdale college
in addition to that all of the work that
we do with these schools is provided at
zero cost to the schools we don't charge
for our curriculum we don't charge for
any of the conferences or the services
that we provide
all we do is ask for the biggest thing
of all which is that they do everything
with excellence
our work's made possible completely by
donations to the college from people who
want to see this mission
spread throughout the k-12 world
and so if you are a member of a school a
teacher in a school and you would like
to learn more about classical education
i hope you will reach out to us because
we'd love to talk to you
and help if there's a way for us to do
that
our email address is k12k12
hillsdale.edu
let me talk to you about the content of
this curriculum and then i'll give you
an introduction to our 1776 curriculum
we describe the education that students
receive in hillsdale classical schools
as american classical education
it's classical education steeped in
the liberal arts and sciences and having
its root
in
you know the ancient world and the
medieval world
but it's attentive to the particular
situation that we find ourselves in and
that our students
must take account for account of
as they prepare for adulthood we are
americans and that means a few things
which i will describe briefly
briefly briefly speaking
when you look at a school that's
providing this american classical
education you'll see a few things
you'll see a return to tried and true
methods
in hillsdale's classical schools
students know how to write in cursive
they know how to diagram sentences
they memorize their math facts and they
don't rely on a calculator
for simple equations or simple
calculations
they know how to
memorize poetry and memorize speeches
and they have
memorized over the course of their
education
some poems and some speeches and some
excerpts from documents that are
essential for human beings to just know
without having to look up
these are schools where teachers
know their stuff we hire teachers who
are highly educated who are deeply
knowledgeable about their subject area
and we create a classroom environment or
allow them to create a classroom
environment in which they can really
teach
prudently
based on the students who are in their
care but also based on their deep
knowledge of the subjects that they're
teaching
this classical education is an education
in skills in knowledge and in virtue
kids in our schools
um
learn all of the skills that you have to
know to be an educated person they learn
how to read they learn how to write they
learn how to take notes and listen and
study and we understand that those
things have to be taught explicitly
we also recognize that
these things are more enjoyable to learn
and that the student
is more successful in school if the
student has interesting things to learn
about so these are schools where
real knowledge is being
being gained from the various early very
earliest grades
we study real history in kindergarten
we learn real things about science
we read novels
and we read the entirety of the novel
rather than a summary or an excerpt of
the novel because it's better to do it
the real way
we think that it's important not to take
shortcuts
with a child's education and that
although
not taking shortcuts
is not the easiest way to do it it's the
most delightful way to do it and it's
the way that actually works for both the
school and the child and so we find that
in these schools although students are
reading more difficult things they're
also enjoying themselves more than they
would with less interesting material
and finally these are schools where we
teach virtue we pay attention to the
type of people that these students are
becoming we want them to know themselves
we want them to be able to make choices
that make sense and we want them to be
people of character
this is a well-rounded education
covering both the humanities and the
sciences it's not an education that
trains students for a particular career
or a particular academic focus
we think there's plenty of time for that
after your k-12 years and we think that
any attempt to try to do that when a
student is still young and in
development may not work and b may limit
the student ultimately
and finally this education is a
preparation for citizenship in this
country and let me tell you a little bit
about why that is
and i'm going to do it by describing the
curriculum to you
hillsdale's 1776 curriculum
is
the way that we've been teaching
american history american government and
civics to students in k through 12
grades k-12
for all of our time in k-12 education
for over 30 years
we saw like everyone saw
over the last couple of years
that there is a massive debate going on
about how students should be taught
history
and at the center of the debate is a
disagreement about what it means to be
an american
and the very goodness of our american
founding
that's a fundamental question
for anyone who's an american because if
there's something fundamentally wrong
with our founding that means there's
something fundamentally wrong with our
country and with us
and so it's urgent for us as americans
to know is our founding a good founding
or not
the good news about studying the
american founding in american history is
that it didn't happen that long ago
and there's a lot of evidence that we
have to understand it the people who
made this country happen did so by
speaking with each other and debating
with each other and writing down what
they thought and keeping records of
their debates
and so we think that the first and most
important way for students to understand
themselves as americans is to look at
what they wrote look at the evidence
we created the curriculum by taking the
scope and sequence
for american history civics and
government out of our k-12 program guide
taking the same curriculum that's being
taught in hillsdale-affiliated schools
and adding lesson plans sample tests and
quizzes and a whole bunch of other
resources to it to make it usable
for any american teacher any american
parent who is looking to make sure their
child receives
a great education
this curriculum is created by real
teachers and it's being used with real
students and has been used with success
by real students for over
several decades
and so this curriculum is reflective of
what happens in hillsdale-affiliated
schools and what could happen
with any american student with the right
curriculum and the right teaching
let me close by talking to you about
some of the principles upon which this
curriculum was
based
we believe that politics is important
and we also believe that when we say the
word politics we often think
the latest presidential election or
whatever is being covered on cnn right
now
um
at its heart that's not what politics is
politics is the study of human beings in
communities
aristotle held that human beings are
meant to live together it's natural for
us to sort ourselves together in
community
and
in other words living alone for your
entire life on an island is not a full
human life we're meant to be together
and it's important that the
the laws and the organization of the
communities that we find ourselves in
are done right because
the nature of the community that we're
in has a lot to do or a lot to say about
the course of our individual life
we if we lived in a despotism it would
prevent us from fully becoming ourselves
as human beings
look at the history of any civilization
look at world history to learn about
the evils of bad laws the evils of bad
regimes and how terrible it is to live
in one as an individual human being
so we recognize the importance of
politics meaning the study of how human
beings can live together justly
and we recognize that we've got to get
that question right for our own
individual happiness
the second thing we think is that
america is important not just because
it's ours and because we know it but
because it is the only civilization if
you look at
world history
to have begun because of
an idea or a conversation about that
very question
what makes
politics what makes human community just
or not just
and if you study our american founding
it's unlike studying the founding of any
other country
there are documents and ideas and
intelligent people debating that very
question and then coming to an answer
about it and crafting a government or a
system of government based upon that
answer
that's rare
and unique
and unprecedented it was unprecedented
at its time
and so there's something
there's something special about that
and something worth preserving about
that
does that mean that everything in
american history is good and that we
should be proud of everything that has
happened in this country absolutely not
um hillsdale or
hillsdale college recognizes something
that we all know as american citizens
that there are moments in our history
that we should be ashamed of that we
should be
that we should be sad about
and that we should try to correct in the
future
but we also recognize that all of those
injustices happened in the context of a
regime that was unlike any other and
that at the very foundation of the
regime in the declaration of
independence was a statement about human
equality and the relationship between
human beings and government that paves
the way for those injustices to be dealt
with
and so we think not only is america
important
not just because it's ours but because
it's good
it's rare and it must be preserved
the things that are good about it must
be saved and the things that need to be
improved about it must be improved
but knowing how to do that as an adult
begins first and all first of all with
an excellent k-12 education in what
america is
and among that
as part of that
is a um
is a study an honest and thorough study
of american history and government
if you read the news about the hillsdale
1776 curriculum you'll see a lot of
headlines
even in friendly papers or friendly
outlets that say that it's a
counterweight to the 1619 project and
that is just absolutely not true
this is a different kind of thing
than curricula that aim to teach
students a particular
um truth about america and to cause them
to do a particular set of things as a
result of that education
if you look at the curriculum which
you'll get a chance to do in just a
second you'll see that it's primarily
primary source documents and questions
this is not a curriculum that has made
up its mind already this is a curriculum
that invites students to ask the big
questions and to answer those questions
responsibly based upon their knowledge
it's something that we think every
american kid can do
we've seen american kids in every type
of setting do this and benefit from it
and we hope it's something that ends up
being helpful to you whether you're a
parent a teacher or somehow involved in
k-12 education
thanks so much for your attention i'd be
happy to answer your questions and i'll
send it back to jordan who's going to
give us a brief tour of the curriculum
thanks thank you dr o'toole uh yeah if
you have if you have any questions
reminder to put them into the q a box
and
along with your first name and where
you're joining us from and uh and we'll
we'll get to those uh towards the end of
this call uh so now i'd like to uh we'd
like to take some time to actually dive
into the curriculum and see what's here
so um again as dr o'toole mentioned it's
available for free download at
k12.hillsdale.edu
and so at this point i'd like to uh take
a look at
what we have um what we've made
available so
uh
the first thing that i'd like to direct
this towards is is the the introduction
to the to the curriculum um uh this is
meant uh in part for teachers because
this will help them to to know how to
implement it in their classrooms but
it's also just for the general public
and anybody who has an interest in
in this in restoring american
education particularly in civics and
history
and so i would just be encourage uh all
of you who are on the call and um and
then others to to look at it to look at
the different sections and uh and kind
of
familiarize yourselves with the
principles behind it and how it's how
it's laid out
so we have a number of different
sections in here some things i'd like to
to highlight uh off the top is um we
have one on on content on about
how do we determine what made it into
the curriculum and the issue here for
those who are in good faith is is we
don't only have so many years uh not
everything can make it into 13 years of
schooling so what we have to we have to
choose right and uh but we we shun a few
ways that uh that people are using
nowadays in order to choose what what
their students learn and one of those
things is uh is putting some sort of
lens onto the history uh
very popular right now to put a lens on
it that views everything in america in a
critical light it only focuses on the
ways in which her citizens or laws have
come up short against the principles in
which she was founded
but uh that that skews it that's only
the echo that's going to give you a
distorted view of your country and
certainly one that um cannot cannot lead
to any sort of of love of country uh
even while acknowledging faults another
one is to focus on the color of one's
skin either it's of historical figures
or of the students
and then
the third one that's pretty popular is
curricula that don't even teach about
history really civics but just about
current events and then actually gives
students ways to take action on those
events in the classrooms and outside of
school in the political arena and that
that one just teaches
students to be pawns to to adults who
have different agendas so this
curriculum rejects all those and as dr
o'toole said this is
this isn't some sort of um uh opposite
the direct opposite of a 1619 curriculum
okay not at all inside we're focusing on
what we think is is true and and the
principle that we uh that we apply here
and it's up to debate what what makes it
in based on this principle but the
principle is what are the things that
have most greatly uh impacted the world
of the student that the student the
world that the student is going to live
their lives
and you know that's the principle we use
to determine what makes into the
curriculum and that means there's a lot
of good things in american history and
we think that good things in american
history
are present at the founding and are the
things they endure over time um compared
to the bad things but it also means that
the ways in which we have failed as a
country are are taught honestly um
so content is one area that that kind of
weighs out what we're teaching here we
also talk about pedagogy advice for
teachers and this is for anybody on the
call uh you know you know when you enter
into a k-12 classroom what should you be
seeing especially if you're studying
about american history and civics and we
think that this should be a teacher-led
classroom but one that is dynamic that
is the teacher telling a story and
telling the story by asking a lot of
questions of students
questions that help the student tell the
story alongside the teacher and his
dynamic and it pulls all these different
resources together um and and it's
aiming ultimately at a sense of wonder
in the students a wonder that propels
them to more learning um about their
country and also a love of country uh
from from there i there are you know
there are other things in introduction
to look at um including a section on
success and what's going to be required
um for this to be to be successful um
and the section and the principles that
that every teacher should be mindful of
if they're going to be employing this
curriculum
i'd like to move ahead and actually look
at what something that the a teacher
would uh would receive
now this curriculum besides the primary
sources we've included it and the sample
tests and things like that otherwise
this is for this is for teachers um
whether it's a teacher in a classroom or
a homeschool parent um you know it's
it's for them to to bring into um into
their instruction so i'm just going to
show walk us through briefly a a middle
school history uh lesson and what what a
unit how the unit is set up
um
so here for example is a unit on the
american founding and we begin with the
different lessons and what they cover in
each one and some pacing guidance
um some overall ideas of why we should
teach this why students need to learn
this some the main ideas that to take
away from the lesson and then some
preliminary thoughts on what teachers to
consider as they begin planning for this
um we we've done a lot of work uh the
college has vetting resources including
our own online courses they're available
for free to anybody in the public and we
align those with the things that are
being taught so if we look at a specific
lesson let's say this first lesson
leading up to them to the declaration of
independence
um you'll notice a few things that that
we that we
really like about about what our schools
do
and
one of them is that we bring back the
facts the facts that students need to
learn um you know that that are
liberating and liberating in the sense
of which you can separate fact from
fiction and so this includes things like
people geography and dates time and
place terms and topics
those are all those are all part of it
and
but they're meaningful they're thought
out they're not just there it's good for
students to memorize things and students
memorize we'll memorize plenty in this
curriculum but it should be meaningful
as well and so students use this
sense of time and place and these people
uh who are not just names but real
people who just as real as the student
themselves having the same thoughts and
desires um and and dealing with similar
circum with similar questions in their
lives
we weave these all together into a
dynamic fashion
uh and then we add some things to it
that hillsdale is is uh particularly
focused on uh one is to for students to
know things by heart
um
there are a number of things here that
uh we think these are these are phrases
and quotations and poems and songs that
every american student should have the
you know have the privilege to encounter
and to know and to carry with them for
the rest of their lives um also we have
uh you know we think that this should be
told as a story um and so we have and
then within that story are smaller
stories and we have these stories for
the american heart
and again these are things that teachers
can share in their classrooms
with students and something that the
student can carry with them and that
brings the brings their lesson alive for
them and finally we have these questions
for the american mind and we think it's
really important to ask good questions
of students and not just questions on
the who what when and where those are
important and foundational um but beyond
that the why the how do you know this
what do you think about this hi you know
what does this show us about human
beings or our country or politics yeah
all those questions are right there and
they're laid out for for students to
encounter
we also we don't shut we
our schools
do not do high-tech uh classrooms uh
there's no one-to-one ipad ratios or
anything like that uh but a good place
to use technology in history is through
the use of images to project a map or a
flag or a battle plan or or a figure
from from history and to talk about that
that image and so we think that's a
fitting place to to include in the
curriculum
um and then we're the hillsdale
where we provide a little bit more
guidance and in no way no way shape or
form are we providing dictates with this
this is all guidance within certain
parameters but we really want teachers
to take the curriculum and own it
themselves to implement it but one
section that is helpful is this keys to
the lesson and we don't do a script that
tells teachers every single thing to say
that's that's that's dictating to them
it's also robs the students of a great
education it's kind of insulting to
teachers they think that all that
they're good for is reading a script
but it's that we have highlighted some
things that we think can be tricky or
that would make a really great lesson if
if a teacher pays attention to them and
so this is these are the keys to the
lesson things for teachers to think
about as they plan
the last resources that we that we offer
to uh teachers here uh is a study guide
on um
uh that that teachers can adapt based on
what they're learning um and sample
tests that go go right along uh go right
along with that um
so these are things that teachers can
employ in their classrooms and that
that's a good way to determine what
students should be should be learning
and something that we think is really
important and all this is a series of
primary sources that students should be
reading from this is the most direct
contact with the past that brings the
past alive for students it's a direct
insight into um into the world and the
thoughts and the deeds of of the people
who actually lived in this history and
so
we have a series of primary sources that
we recommend
um and we broke it we've given some
basic background information that really
helps students get into the particular
moment in which this document arises and
then we have it laid out so that so
students can readily access it and
annotate it and make it read it and make
it their own so there are
plenty of of these of these resources
throughout the curriculum
now
i think that uh what we do when we take
all this uh what you know this is a k-12
curriculum it's it's for every grade
level um and how we've broken it down is
by grade level bands k through two third
through fifth grade sixth or eighth
grade or middle school and nine through
twelfth grade for high school and across
that they will study american history
uh since the civil war uh four times
through the civil war four times modern
american history twice
not to mention two uh whole things on
american civics in government so it's a
it's a robust curriculum uh
uh and and it asks it asks
we put forward this is what we think
american child should study and to learn
about their country
um now dr o'toole mentioned some things
about you know how do we handle the
times when america has failed and things
like that and we put them side by side
they're all there it's part of the story
we do think that the good uh endures in
all this and we do think the american
uh founding and this is not a debatable
point but compared to any place else in
the world at the time or leading up to
it had no country even founded on
principles such as america was and then
the successes and achievements that have
been gained by referencing those
principles are also unparalleled and so
uh but we don't put a lens on it we
don't put anything like that it's it's
it's it's the his it's the history it's
the truth it's an honest account of the
past and when it comes to individuals in
that they're just as fallible as as we
are nowadays and it's good for students
to see that about that that's true not
only of people in the past but
themselves and so they see the heroic
things they do and the ways in which
they've come up short
and they realize it's can be very
difficult to make a total judgment in
somebody's life or character uh
especially in the negative manner when
you think that we have
in many ways the sensibilities we have
nowadays looking back are the results of
the principles of the declaration
independence
um you know so this is this is an
unbiased curriculum that we encourage
people to see for themselves you know uh
look into it um you know there's we'll
put it up against anything that's out
there and we think it's really
curriculum that can heal unite america
rather than uh further inflame and
divide it and we think that's what
students deserve so uh so that that's
just a little bit of an introduction to
what the curriculum entails and what it
looks like um you know we at this point
we'd like to open it up to uh to your
questions and
any thoughts you you may have so again
if you have any questions put them into
the q a box with your name and where
you're from um so uh i think what one
first question maybe dr atul can take a
stab at it and i can follow up with if
necessary but uh uh jd from texas uh is
asking you know how does this does this
work in public schools uh you know
especially
given the current political climate
that's out there uh and kind of as a
follow-up to that you know how is this
fit with state testing and state
standards
yeah that's a great question um the
answer is absolutely yes
um
let me explain a little bit about how
state standards work
um
state standards depends on the state but
generally speaking those are decided
upon
um by some combination of the of the
governor's office the legislature and
the department of education or the state
you know state department of education
they call it different things
um there are different procedures for it
but whatever whatever the procedure
the standards are a set of general
requirements that all public and public
charter school students must
must reach
and many of our schools are public
charter schools and so they they meet
the standards that are applicable to
that state
because the standards are by definition
sort of a
baseline requirement for what elementary
and secondary age students must learn
there's actually plenty of time in the
school day to do things that are beyond
the standards
especially if you use your time
efficiently as we do in classical
schools we teach bell to bell
students have a full school day all the
way through 12th grade
and they learn the habits of mind and
the and the content knowledge that
enable them to really do quite a lot in
school
one example is
i don't know of a state that requires
latin and yet all of the students in
hillsdale classical schools take latin
and reach proficiency in latin meaning
translation ability by the time they get
to high school
that's possible because we're just
efficient with our time and we have kids
who know how to do that and teachers who
know how to do that
before we work with a with a new state
or a school in a new state we do an
alignment between our curriculum our
scope and sequence
and the um and the state standards and
we don't go into a state unless we're
confident that we can follow the law and
also provide a classical education to
these kids
i have yet to see a state in which it is
impossible
it's possible that there's a state out
there in which it cannot be done but i
have yet to find one
and so i hope that's encouraging um kids
kids can do this and it can be done
under state law
yeah and the um you know a lot of the
standards that are out there they're not
in and of themselves always
bad standards but they leave the door
open for a lot of bad things to be
included
at the curriculum level at the school
level and and so um like dr o'toole says
this far surpasses uh a lot of the
requirements that that states have
um you know and so so it's definitely
meant for public schools you know these
charter schools that we that we work
with um those are public schools uh and
so you know so it it certainly does
given the political climate um you know
i think this it's a it's a question of
um you know who who makes these
decisions and how can this be used and
um rose from florida had a had a has a
similar or a question that's that
follows on this which is how do you
introduce this to your local school and
that's a really great question um so one
thing to do is to find out where
curriculum
decisions are are being made in your
locality or in your state
sometimes it's at the state level but
oftentimes the state sets out the
standards and then they sometimes will
recommend
certain curricula but more often than
not they will let leave that up to the
local district and that's usually a
superintendent or school board decision
that that that make that they make to
determine what type of curriculum
they're going to use and so
with that those are the people that you
may want to introduce this to
um and i think the introduction is a
great way to start uh the whole
curriculum when you add it all up across
all those grades and you know we've only
released the first two thirds of it
we're working on the final uh units for
the american history that should be
released in early 2022
but so far it's adding up to over 2000
pages right so you're not going to want
to hand that to to anybody who's uh
right off the bat but the but the
introductions
uh you know 30 pages or so and so that's
and that's can be geared a little bit
more towards them so i would invite you
know i probably suggest that people
download it uh print it off or send it
uh
you know send a link um to uh to school
board members introduce at a school
board meeting even you could you could
submit into the minutes that'd be fine
um or talk with the superintendent but
do it politely do it respectfully ask
people for their consideration
i think one of the things that
that we've realized out there is that
there's been a lot of
fun you know
finally a lot of people have woken up to
um to the to the issues that are going
on in education uh we've we their school
choice is one of them but also now what
is actually being taught in the
classrooms and it's right for them to to
notice these things that are awry
they're wrong for the country wrong for
our students
um but at a certain point there's going
to have to be an alternative put forward
you need something positive to run on to
to run on and to get to to make a change
and so and we think that our curriculum
can fit that bill um we don't know of
anything that's quite like it out there
uh it's also based on real students in
real classrooms it's actually happening
and so i would suggest uh find out who
it is that makes these curriculum
decisions and and and you can recommend
this to them i also suggest that uh any
teacher anywhere can adopt can
use this for their own knowledge or to
supplement what they're already doing
that happens all the time in education
that teachers will pull in things that
are not necessarily
the what this what the school the what
the school standard is but that's fine
it's expected it's called making your
lessons better so um so and any teacher
can do this we already have teachers in
over 1300 schools across the country who
have downloaded the curriculum for for
use in their classrooms
so
um
uh yeah
next question here those are really
great questions jennifer from california
asked how does a first-time homeschool
mom do this seems like a lot of prep
work and reading for the parents uh dr
atul do you want to
weigh in on that
yeah we're working hard on this
more and more parents are wanting to
supplement or maybe even take
homeschooling into
into their own hands
and
this curriculum is the beginning of a
series of resources that we're putting
together for homeschooling families
for more you can go and to learn about
how this curriculum fits into the entire
american classical program that we offer
to our schools you can go to k12 at home
k12athome.hillsdale.edu
there's a there are a number of videos
there for parents whether you're a
parent of a child in public school who
wants to know
is this is what my child's learning you
know age-appropriate and
you know quality
whether you're a parent who's thinking
about homeschooling or whether you're a
parent who is already homeschooling
there's a lot of stuff there to
introduce you to some elements of
classical education
more is coming we are working on
adapting this k-12 program guide our
curriculum for homeschooling use and
we're going to be piloting that next
year and then releasing it we hope to
the general public the following year
in the meantime there are a lot of
resources
out there that will help you homeschool
your child or supplement your child's
public or private school education
you can go to hillsdale's online courses
they're really good they're they're
closely related to if not identical to
the the kinds of things that are in a
classical education
and they're interesting to watch they're
beautifully produced and they're taught
by some of the best professors here at
the college and each lecture is just 20
or 30 minutes long and so it's a great
way to
dip your toe into the classical world
shore yourself up on history or
mathematics or whatever it is
and what you'll learn from that is um
you'll you'll gather recommendations for
further reading
and you can use that to to you know
develop your own understanding
and then
gather you know and then use that with
your child
it is true that
homeschooling a child using a classical
curriculum is a serious endeavor
there's not a way to make it really easy
our goal is to make it really clear
and then to give parents recommendations
about how to make it work for their
family some parents will join a co-op
they'll find other parents and they'll
divide the teaching among themselves
sometimes they hire a teacher to come in
some parents will do it you know within
their own family
that's all a local decision you're the
one who knows your child you're the one
who
you know can figure out what works best
for you our job is just to give you a
place to start and that's right now k12
at home.hillsdale.edu
yeah and i'd add and just say that um
you know the best teaching depends on p
the teacher knowing what they're what
they're teaching and letting their love
of
of what they've studied and the love of
sharing it with their student arises
from that goes for home school parents
as well and so um you know i i just say
take a start at it someplace it doesn't
mean you know like i said this this is
guidance not dictates uh this does not
mean you have to do every single thing
that's in there uh you know start start
where you can more follow you know see
where it goes follow uh follow what
you're what you're loving to learn and
um and pull on that you know sometimes
in our school sometimes um especially
the first years of schools math and
literacy are
uh it's they're very they're very
important and it's important to get
everybody on the same page and um some
days we say to teachers look if you get
in there you pull one of these read
aloud books that we have from this
curriculum and you read that out to your
your your class in an engaging manner
and ask good questions of them that's
that's going to be a great great start
to the education um so just encourage
don't feel you know there's a lot there
but we cut we want to put everything on
the table uh it's we it's really up to
the teacher or the homeschool parent to
to cut where they where they feel uh is
necessary to to get it done and if
you're not homeschooling um you can
still use this as dr
mentioned as kind of a touchstone to
compare to what your child is learning
in school um you know so you know how is
this compared to what they're actually
studying um in in the classrooms and and
that can be a good way to to navigate
that um
i
next question uh deborah from
connecticut uh you know asked how does
this curriculum make uh minority
students feel comfortable with american
history and and uh and yeah that's a
good question um i'll i'll i can start
off with it if dr toole has anything to
add uh she she can um you know i i think
uh the the question itself may be a
little bit of uh
uh a a little off on where it's coming
from um and the reason for that is i
think a lot of students as with any
story that they're entering into and
that's how we teach this principally as
a story
and a story in the past
they're they're taught to be
uncomfortable with american history
because they've been told to be
uncomfortable about american history by
adults
and we don't tell the student what to
think about anything in history we
present the history to them and so i
think the key here is everybody is
looking at this uh
step to back from history and then
trying to put ourselves into the shoes
of the characters who are there right so
it's no longer you who are in the that
you who are studying it but you are part
of of that history and you're and you're
in it and you're observing it you're
witnessing it as an objective bystander
bystander there um and insofar as things
come up from there then they're dealt
with but i think the the main thing that
we see here is that this is the story of
human beings and the curriculum doesn't
bring up race as a determining factor
about why we study somebody okay or or
of the students themselves right
like the key thing here is that these
are all human beings who have the same
human nature who are striving for the
similar things and who are equally uh
you know
capable of great things and also capable
of awful things and we put everybody on
on that level student historical figures
teacher that's our starting point and i
think that's a really healthy and the
truthful way to to begin approaching i
don't know if dr o'toole has
anything else that she may want to add
to that
oh i think that's great
so uh thank you for uh thank you for
joining us this this afternoon um you
know we really value you taking the time
to
um to learn more about hillsdale college
hillsdale college k-12 education in the
hillsdale 1776 curriculum um you know
this we're really excited about it
it's gaining a lot of traction
and but we think that the main way for
it to really be successful is by
ordinary citizens to um to care to to
share it
and to to learn about their country
themselves and so uh we really
appreciate your your interest and
support and